well
uh let me ask you a little bit about ego
and fame
which is very interesting the way you're
talking
given that you're one of the
biggest intellects living intellects and
minds
of our time and there's a lot of people
that really love you
and um almost uh elevate you to a sort
of certain kind of status where you're
like the guru
i'm surprised you didn't show up in a
robe in fact um
is there a hoodie that's the that's not
the
highest status garment one can wear now
the socially acceptable version of the
of the robe if you're a billionaire
is there something you can say about
managing the effects of fame
on your own mind on the not creating
this
you know when you wake up in the morning
when you look up in the mirror
how do you get your ego not to
grow exponentially your conception of
salt to grow exponentially because
there's so many people feeding that
is there something to be said about this
it's really not hard because
i mean i feel like i have a pretty clear
sense of my
strengths and weaknesses and i i don't
feel like it's
i mean i don't honestly i don't feel
like i suffer from much grandiosity
i just have a you know there's so many
things i'm not good at there's so many
things i will you know given the
the remaining 8000 days at best
i will never get good at i would love to
be good at these things uh
so it's just it's easy to feel
diminished by comparison with the
the talents of others do you remind
yourself of all the things that you're
not competent in is i mean like they're
just on display for me every day that i
appreciate the
the talents of others but you notice
them i'm i'm sure stalin and hitler did
not notice
all the ways in which they were uh i
mean this is why
absolute power corrupts absolutely is
you stop noticing the things
in which you're ridiculous and wrong
right yeah no i
am not to compare you to yeah yeah
well i'm sure there's an inner stalling
in there somewhere uh
well we all have to hopefully he'll
carry a baby stop where's better clothes
and i'm not going to grow that mustache
those concerns don't map on
they don't map on to me for a bunch of
reasons but one is i also have a very
peculiar audience
like i i'm just you know
i've been appreciating this for a few
years but it's it's i'm just
now beginning to understand that there
are many people who have
audiences of my size or larger that have
a very different experience of having an
audience than i do
i have i have curated for better or
worse
a a peculiar audience and
the net result of that is
virtually any time i say anything of
substance
something like half of my audience my
real audience not haters from outside my
audience but my audience
is just revolts over it right they just
like oh my god i can't believe you said
like you you're such a schmuck right
yeah they revolt with rigor and
intellectual sophistication
or not or not but i mean it's like but
but people who are like so i mean the
clearest case is
you know i haven't have whatever
audience i have and then trump appears
on the scene and i discover that
something like 20 of my audience just
went
straight to trump and couldn't believe i
didn't follow them there they were just
aghast that i didn't see that trump was
obviously
exactly what we needed for for uh to
steer the ship of state for the next
four years uh and then four years beyond
that
so like so that's one example
so if whenever i said anything about
trump i would hear from people
who loved more or less everything else i
was up to and had for years
but everything i said about trump just
gave me pure pain from this this
quadrant of my audience
but then saying the same thing happens
when i say
something about the derangement of the
far left anything i say about wokeness
right or identity politics same kind of
punishment signal from us
again people who are core to my audience
like i've read all
i read all your books i'm using your
meditation app
i love what you'd say about science and
but you are so
wrong about politics and you're you know
i'm starting to think you're a racist
[ __ ] for everything you said about
about identity politics and there's so
many
the free will topic is just like this
it's like i
just they love what i'm saying about
consciousness
and the mind and they love to hear me
talk about physics with physicists and
it's all good this free will stuff is i
cannot believe you don't see how wrong
you are what a [ __ ] embarrassment you
are
uh so but i'm starting to notice that
there are other people
who don't have this experience of having
an audience
because they have just take the trump
woke dichotomy
they just castigated trump the same way
i did
but they never say anything bad about
the far left so they never get this
punishment signal or they or you flip it
they
they they're all about the insanity of
critical race theory now they'll they we
we connect all those dots the same way
but they never really specified what was
wrong with trump
or they thought there was a lot right
with trump and they they
got all the pleasure of that and so they
have much more homogenized
audiences and so my
my experience is so just to come back to
you know this experience of fame or
quasi fame i mean it's
true truth is not real fame but it's
it's still it's it there's an audience
there um
it is a it's now an experience where
basically whatever i put out
i notice a ton of negativity coming back
at me
and it just it is what it is i mean now
now it's like i used to think wait a
minute there's got to be
some way for me to communicate more
clearly here so as not to get
this kind of lunatic response
from my own audience from like people
who are who are showing all the signs of
of we've been here for years for a
reason right these are not just trolls
and so i think okay i'm going to take 10
more minutes and really just
tell you what it should be absolutely
clear about what's wrong with trump
right i've done this a few times but i
got a thing i got to do this again
or wait a minute how are they not
getting
that these episodes of police violence
are so obviously different from one
another
that you can't describe all of them to
[Music]
yet another racist maniac on the police
force you know killing someone based on
his racism
last time i talked spoke about this it
was pure pain but i
just got to try again now at a certain
point i i mean i'm
starting to feel like all right i just i
have to be
i have to cease again it comes back to
this expectation that there shouldn't be
fires
right like i feel like if i could just
play my game
impeccably the people who actually care
what i think
will follow me when i
hit trump and hit free will and hit the
woke and hit
whatever it is what how we should
respond to the coronavirus you know i
mean
vaccines you know are they a thing right
like there's such derangement
in in uh our information space now that
i mean i guess you know some people
could be getting more of this than i
expect but i i just noticed that
you know many of our our friends who are
in the same game
have more homogenized audiences and
don't get i mean
they've they've successfully filtered
out the people who are going to
despise them on this next topic and i
you know i would i would imagine you are
have a different experience of having a
podcast than i do at this point i'm sure
you
get haters but i would imagine you're uh
you're more streamlined i actually don't
like the word haters because it kind of
presumes that uh it puts people in a bin
i think we're all have like baby haters
inside of us and we just apply them and
some people
enjoy doing that more than others for
particular periods of time
i think you're gonna almost see hating
on the internet as a video game that you
just play
and it's fun but then you can put it
down and walk away and
uh no i i certainly have a bunch of
people that are very critical
i can list all the ways but does it feel
like it on any given topic does it feel
like it's
an actual title surge where it's like 30
of your audience
and then the other 30 of your audience
from podcast to podcast
no that's happening to me all the time
now
you